there are a lot of ways you can
establish status over another man like
Jorge
firm handshake
displays of wealth
and Feats of Strength
interesting moving that rug was the
hardest thing in the world for you when
I needed to practice tap dancing there
are also more subtle moves what I call
microaggressions call them by the wrong
name
throws them off the moment he meets you
is
Spanish
who's got the Great Taste that'd be me
nice uh hello
so uh
you and Gloria used to yep
hey so he was a little more handsome
than you were expecting but pull
yourself together man
so Jorge
um you were Gloria's boyfriend right
before Javier yeah and a little during
you know she kind of bounced around
between the two of us um where is she
anyway I got to be at a Dodger game in
an hour oh you like sports that's
fantastic I try to get this one into
baseball no go actually I hate baseball
I'm here to sing the national anthem I'm
an opera singer I just finished two
months at La Scala The House That
tuscanini Built yeah well it's been
rebuilt a few times you know a bunch of
opera singers prancing around it uh
takes this toll on the foundation hey
I'm here to pick up Mom's old Boombox
from Storage she needs it for
how many Manny's do you see through
these things that's Gloria's
ex-boyfriend wait how far X roughly 20
years
oh my God is it possible what does
Gloria saying she hasn't even seen him
yet the odd bit is these two clones
don't see the resemblance maybe she
won't either I'm not going to force it
on her I mean it's no easy thing to say
is there a chance you're so dumb you
don't even know who the father of your
baby is we could do a DNA test I could
do one at the lab at school and then you
would have a definitive answer if it
comes back negative you don't even
really have to tell Gloria well what it
is saliva we take these two down with a
Sizzler and your squeegee which you need
off the salad bar window you use hairs
now
good you're home one second
I'm creating that new shirt so handsome
Gloria
oh
I thought you were money good you're
caught up now
I know I put on a few but uh they don't
take you seriously as an opera singer
when you're too skinny you know what
happens when the thin lady sings
show just keeps going it's wonderful to
see you
I'm gonna go and open a bottle of wine
that Jorge could be Jorge mentioned you
bounced around between him and Javier
how much bouncing did you do
technically it's possible
is money going to handle this it's not
great you know he doesn't respond well
to surprises remember how upset he got
when he found out those mashed potatoes
were really just whipped cauliflower
what are we going to do
okay Grandpa got oh Gloria you're here
what do you bring with you besides that
guilty look okay in order to get a
definitive answer I had Alex perform a
DNA test
hey lotion is on the sink Jorge
turns out I'm not the only one who
suffers from dry navel
uh Alex why do you have a medical form
with my name on it
I don't think I should be the one to
explain this
Manny as you know your mother and Jorge
had a relationship
you're a lot alike and it made us
curious as to whether
uh are you saying this is a DNA test
your mom didn't even find out until
today
I don't even know how to react
so my whole childhood was a lie
I thought Javier was my dad now he's
just some stranger who gave me baths
listen buddy
it's not who brings you into the world
it's what you do when you're there
you're not Javier you're not this guy
you're you and what you are is amazing
and for the record I've been your dad
since you're 10 and I'm gonna be your
dad until I'm gone
I love you and I always will
I love you too Jay
[Laughter]
yes
now who doesn't understand a joke what I
never dated Jorge he's the butcher at
the grocery store I just thought that he
looked like money why would you do that
because you said that I didn't
understand funny I didn't know you were
going to take the prank this far you
made Grandpa cry I know he's like I love
you and I always win
[Laughter]
[Music]